[Music]
as the developer today you can launch
solutions faster than ever
building on the capabilities of google
cloud platform
your custom services and third-party
apis
but as more and more services are
integrated your solutions can increase
the complexity becoming hard to
understand and even harder to develop
debug and visualize you could write
custom services to manage these
integrations and host them in manually
maintained virtual machines
or link them together with a carefully
crafted event driven architecture
even with event driven architecture
observing the progress of a workflow
execution
is nearly impossible especially when a
workflow might run for hours
days or even months implementing error
handling can be difficult when something
fails along the chain of events
it becomes burdensome to track down plus
chaining services together gives you a
growing distributed system
with less predictable behavior over time
changes to one workflow may break
another workflow
also using those events without a
central definition of the entire
workflow it can be hard to see the full
picture and make appropriate changes
so how can you best use the power of
different services in your custom
workflow without all of these issues
by using google cloud workflows cloud
workflows is a fully managed service
that gives you the power to integrate
microservices
and apis while also error handling and
streamlining future development
from one central place you can describe
steps to combine custom services google
cloud products and anything
with http apis into an automated
workflow
and because it's serverless workflow
skills meet your demand
so you only pay for what you use so how
does it
work let's look at the two primary use
cases
event driven workflows and batch jobs
event driven workflows execute when a
certain trigger happens
for example let's say one of your
ecommerce customers has just placed an
order and they need their invoice
a new ecommerce event order kicks off
the workflow
first up a cloud run app receives data
from the event
and generates a pdf then the pdf is
passed to a cloud function that encrypts
and compresses it into a zip file
and finally the pdf is sent to a
third-party email api
sending the invoice to the customer
batch workflows consist
of running large jobs potentially on a
regular basis
for example a nightly job to check on
any incomplete orders from your
ecommerce site
each night at midnight the workflow is
kicked off the database is queried for
any incomplete orders in the past 24
hours
each valid account is sent to a cloud
function that can generate a
personalized offer
the offer is sent to a separate function
to generate an email
and those emails are sent using the same
third party api
in both cases workflow gives you a
holistic approach to workflow
management from the user interface or
from your favorite editor
you can build custom workflows and
investigate ones that are already
running
when calling other google cloud services
workflow handles all the underlying
details
like transport authentication and
waiting for long-running operations
google cloud iam makes it even easier to
manage permissions so you don't need to
worry about unauthenticated requests
workflow also gives you full visibility
into what's happening you can see each
step
execute as your workflow handles errors
retries and recovers from failures
even for third party apis plus workflow
executes with low latency
and no cold start with fully managed
scaling making them ideal for event
driven tasks
if your workflow is a batch
orchestration workflow for data
engineering or etl
you may want to look at google cloud
composer built on apache airflow with
data analysis focused integration
it's built for workflows involving data
analysis on the other hand if your
workflow is focused on orchestrating
work done by services
cloud workflow delivers a fully managed
easy to use solution
bring your mission critical workflows to
google cloud workflows to discover how
quickly you can deploy
powerful solutions while knowing
everything will scale
operate reliably in a fully managed cost
effective
environment check out cloud.google.com
workflows to learn more and to try it
out yourself
[Music]